and this is exactly why you should not
take average size books and split them
into two movies for the big screen just
never makes it a smooth ride The Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 so the Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 is a film
adaptation of the second half of the
final Hunger Games book and in that
we're following the final moves of
Katniss Everdeen trying to dethrone
president douche snow yeah his name is
snow and he's a complete bastard which
officially might make Panem Westeros
contrary to what my Indra would entail
there is enjoyment in this movie first
of all I like some of the directions
they took with the character
specifically with Peeta you know they
got him at the end of the last movie
Pete is kind of messed up in the head
spoiler alert so he's on this journey
with Katniss and crew and the whole time
you're like why on earth are they taking
him with him and there is a story-based
reason for it in the movie it's kind of
allowed for some character development
with Peeta and made him a deeper
character than he's ever been because we
never really got that before he was just
one of the guys in the love triangle and
the action scenes were really exciting I
see when the tars coming down that you
saw in the trailer all the traps were
big they were grandeur everything you
would expect the game makers and the
Hunger Games to make in a city that was
damn entertaining there was just one
scene that was straight up from the
movie aleene's that's what I thought
anyway there chest deep and water they
got the sooner they got the right our
thing I'll be me it's really dark the
ambience it's kind of the same you hear
creepy crawlies but you don't really
know what's ahead and what's around them
I don't know where the line actually is
that divides paying homage to ripping
off but I just straight-up thought the
movie aliens what this movie does have
problems to me you just look at the
characters they took all this time in
the last movie otherwise known as the
first half of the book this movie is
based on they built these characters up
they never really explore in this one
they're just gonna like alright we built
them up be after in the movies don't if
I'm being completely honest Katniss by
yourself is she's not really an
interesting person to me we all love her
we're all rooting for I think that's
because she's played by Jennifer
Lawrence and we all love Jennifer
Lawrence but Katniss as a person I'm
gonna speak plain she's just kind of
boring and some of the pacing in this
movie is some of the scenes in this
movie dragged on there was just a couple
minutes too long and I was thinking
about it it's because they divided this
one average-sized book into two movies
so when they did that they're like okay
now we have two movies
that if we're true to the book we'll
probably be an hour and 15 minutes long
each so we have to fill it in with
filler kinda seems like that old
classmate from high school after high
school you run to him in the Malta oh
man hey what's up Oh hands going on
nothing much I'm doing this what are you
doing I'm doing this all right that's
cool yeah let's go this is so what else
you have to know know that the
conversation should be over but you're
just trying to keep it going and it
doesn't work for this for this
conversation to be optimal it had to
have ended right there when the pause
happened but you didn't you're keeping
it going and it's hurting the
conversations hurting this moment that
happens a lot in this movie they just
keep talking and it's not character
development they're not developing the
characters at all they're just talking
to filling the gaps to fill in the time
you just feel like it's wasting your
time the biggest offender of this is the
end I'm all about resolution in a saga
about revolution but holy [ __ ] this
ending alone should have been 15 minutes
shorter there's like the Lord of the
Rings Return of the King wrap up with
none of the characters you really got
that attached to and none of the lengths
to justify it Lord of the Rings like a
12 hour saga and the ending alone takes
a directional turn that I respect and I
was interested in that directional turn
although one stupid-ass thing happens
and didn't need to happen it just didn't
need to happen in the movie however
going with it it was interesting and
then things happened and kept happening
and you're like you can end now if it
was just a movie with prolonged
resolution that wasn't obviously
resolution for the sake of drawing out
the running time of this movie so they
felt like they were justified in
dividing the book into two movies I can
deal with it but in this case no not
today guys in the end The Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 2 was an enjoyable movie
I enjoyed it I had fun with it I enjoyed
seeing Katniss make the final moves
against snow the action was exciting but
it being resolution this is the thing
that's gonna stitch together the entire
saga ultimately the final chapter of a
saga is going to justify everything that
you've walked through to get to this
moment and in the end it's just glaring
that the pacing took a huge hit in this
movie because they divided the last book
into two movies and they should never
have done that so can we just stop doing
that Hollywood please because there's
nothing but hurt the story as a whole I
know it feels like I'm bitching about
this movie way more than I want to but I
need to illustrate the flaws in this
movie however you should take away from
this I did enjoy the Hunger
James Mockingjay part 2 and I will say
the Hunger Games Mockingjay part 2 is a
good time no alcohol required right so
all for the Hunger Games movies have you
seen them what did you think about him
and what was your favorite one and what
ever you think comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]